[Music]
[Registered Nurse:] Okay, next patient, Mr. Silva. 40 percent. Title volume800. Rate 10....five. Last gas, CO2 was up.
Why does the resident have all that stuff on? Waita minute. There's blood and body fluid precautions.
Who's the attending? Dr. Daniels, InfectiousDisease. Oh great!  This guy's got AIDS!
They never tell, Respiratory Care anything.Well it was bound to happen sooner or later.
[Clinical Instructor:] We want to focus on one particular aspect
of the AIDS crisis so to speak. The emotionalreactions that people have, the emotional
overreactions that people have, and concerns withworking with AIDS patients.
[Nurse 1:] The doctors aren'talways honest, about the patient having AIDS.  We'vehad them not tell us before.
[Clinical Instructor:] The fear of dishonesty or not full disclosure. [Nurse 2:] What is the medical worldnot telling us?
[Clinical Instructor:] Is the medical community tellingall? What else? [Nurse 3:] You have to deal with whatevercomes through the door. You don't know the
background of these people. Anyone is a potentialAIDS patient. As well as, you know, having any other
number of problems. And it's not always a veryclean business. It gets pretty messy sometimes.
[Nurse 4:] You don't want to do mouth-to-mouth on anybody. [Clinical Instructor:] Yeah,  yeah.  [Nurse 4:] Because you don't know who's been
exposed and it's not telling. Or who's been exposedand they don't know it.
[Practitioner:] My husband called me onenight at work. And I told him I was taking care ofan AIDS patient. We have a newborn.
He told me to leave my clothes at the back door, he'd burn him when hegot home.
[Nurse 5:] We have some departments that will comeonto the floor and they'll see a blood and bodysecretion isolation, precaution label on the door.
Everything they need to follow is right there. But they want to know what the patient has.
[Clinical Instructor:] Ohof course, because they want to know so that thenthey can freak out. Exactly. Tell me more. Whatelse?
[Nurse 6:] There's still those group of questions thatare not answered. The disease isn't old enough.
How long is it gonna stay latent? When can it activate? There are a lot of things out there that we justdon't know.
[Clinical Instructor:] I think there are two issues. AndI say there's two issues, it's not either/or.
One is to have the information, theeducation, the knowledge,
the wisdomto have the policies and procedures all clearlylaid out to the best that you possibly can.
But the second issue is I can guarantee,  you cantalk till you die, of the facts. And if somebody's
gonna be overly emotional and over-reactive? It's just like talking to a wall.
[Nurse 7:] Our first contactwith the patient, we're just sort of cold. I mean we accept them and then all of a sudden
you start looking through the history and youfind out. Oh, this patient is a possible AIDS. And your mind starts racing, oh my goodness what do I do.
And suddenly you know you change your attitude.
[Clinical Instructor:] What if I get it myself. That's the bottom line issue. We've got all these other dimensions,
all theseother factors that we worry about, the policiesand the procedures and the information and the nature of the patient and all that kind ofstuff.
But the only reason why we're really worriedabout all this kind of stuff, is the bottom line.
Can I possibly get it? Now, how do you keep it inits perspective. How do you do that mentally?
How do you do that emotionally? See the worstthing in the world would be, to say, "oh come on
there's no problem. Come on it's really safe. Allthese people are just trying to make waves."
Well, the truth is, there is that tiny little window. Thatwindow opens up a possibility not to have a cold.
Not to have a sniffle. But it's a long and painfuldeath, for most patients. When you raise the
stakes to that level of seriousness. That littlewindow suddenly becomes an enormous issue.
[Practitioner:] Dear sis,I'm about to leave for work. Dan and the kids arestill in bed. I'm working ICU now and I like it alot.
But Dan, is really giving me a hard time aboutthe AIDS patients. He's convinced that I'm going
to bring the virus home and expose the kids. I'vetried to talk to him about the precautions we take.
But he just keeps insisting that I go back to PEDS. I'm not sure how I'm going to deal with this.
[Nurse 8:] Idon't talk about it to my husband.  Which isn't fair because if I, if, you know, if something bad happens
at work and I go home and I can tell him. You know. I had a baby die today and he like, "oh I'm
so sorry." You know, "are you feeling okay about itnow?" But if I had to go work with an AIDS patient
that was very ill and had a lot of secretionsand I was kind of uptight about it. I can't go
home and tell him. [Clinical Instructor:] That one of your major supportsystems isn't available to you in this context.
[Husband:] So what's the matter with you? [Wife/Nurse:] the one in 14. Hisboyfriend or lover or whatever you call it,  it's been
in the room with him for about 15 minutes.They're just hugging, oblivious to the world.
[Husband:] Well they've been together for nine years, the guy doesn't have much longer to live.
[Wife/Nurse:] I know that, but it doesn't change the way I feel!
[Clinical Instructor:] What about the business of homosexualityand people's personal reactions to it?
Some of you may say hey I don't have anyproblem with it at all. It doesn't bother me
at all. Somebody wants to be gay, if somebody wantsto be heterosexual, bisexual, I couldn't care less.
Some people have said I just kind of don't like.It makes me uncomfortable. Some people
say, "it's downright sick.
They deserve what they got, the bastards!"
It comes out in that whole range. In many casesyou'll hear people saying that, "This is the Lord's
Wrath, being brought down, upon those people!"Do you ever find yourself starting to worry,
about that stuff? A particular patient thatyou know just passed through. Maybe had some
indication that they were high-risk patientfor some reason. [Nurse 3:] Makes me extremely disgusted
with that whole sect of the population. Then I worry that I can't provide the level of carefor that population group. That would, you know, thatyou would be perfectly capable of providing for
anyone else. [Clinical Instructor:] Yeah, and that's tough to dealwith, I mean you're a professional person too. But
you still have to deal with your own personalreactions. But what we're really concerned about
here, is how do you make sure that you'renot exacerbating the emotional overreaction.
Nobody's denying that it's serious. Nobody'sdenying that there's that tiny little window.
How do you deal with that window in a functionaleffective rational manner? That's the issue that's
the focus here. Now let me show you somethingabout that. We've got, (point) A's here. Now (point) A's are specific
situations. That you run into, that you have todeal with there's specific situations that you
run into on a day-to-day basis. It might be havingto draw blood. It might be having somebody come
into the emergency room with several symptoms, that might be indicative of an AIDS patient.
Now (point) C's, represent two things, your feelingsand your behavior. Now, in that situation, how
you respond to that situation. Now there's fourscrewball feelings. There's four screwball feelings
that, if you allow yourself to experience one of these four feelings, you are going to not handle
the situation as effectively as you could. Youwill overreact. The first one is, 'excessive anxiety'.
If you get yourself overly anxious, uptight, worried, upset, you could call it a lot of different words.
But if you get yourself, excessively anxious, you'regoing to overreact and not handle that situation
as effectively or as professionally as you'dlike. The second one is, 'excessive anger'. If you
get yourself overly angry, disgusted, outraged.You are not going to handle that situation or
that patient as effectively or professionally asyou'd like. The third one, I call it, 'depression'.
But a lot of people just call it, burnout. There'sno real strong emotional response. It's just like
I've had it. The fourth is, 'guilt'. It's
there. Let's say that the person at, point C,
gets angry. [Husband:] You didn't say
anything to either of them, did you?
[Wife/Nurse:] I didn't say a word, [Husband:] But what did you do? [Wife/Nurse:] I didthe job I was supposed to do and then I left.
[Clinical Instructor:] Now it might be subtle. It might be whatpsychologists call, 'passive aggressive
behavior'.  You know, just the abrupt "boom, boom,boom", not being quite as sensitive. Certainly not
being responsive to the emotional state of thepatient. See those are the behaviors at point C.
You could take any one of these things, dealingwith your spouse or relatives. What's the feeling?
[[Practitioner:] It sounds crazy, but at times I actually start tofeel guilty about caring for our AIDS patients.
Dan's got this notion in his head that I canpick and choose who I care for. I can just
imagine what he'd say, if he saw me doing someof the procedures that I have to do. I know he'd
absolutely blow up, to make matters worse. He's beentalking to mom and she's starting to ask questions.
That's all I need, to have the whole family on mycase. [Clinical Instructor:] Let's say, that you're simply uh, the first
time you had to deal with an AIDS patient. What wasthe likely feeling? You know, the first time? Yeah
anxiety, right. [Practitioner:] Now calm down. I've got to do this bythe numbers. Thank God, this guy's really out of it.
Should Ii call my supervisor? Maybe
I should get someone to assist?
No, that's ridiculous! Come on, calm down! You'vedone a thousand blood gases. [Clinical Instructor:] If I said to you,
if you want to make sure, that you handle thesesituations in a professional manner. Very simple.
Just make sure that you never get yourself, excessively anxious, angry depressed or guilty.
Piece of cake right? Done, no problem. It'snot that simple, is it? This is where
people make the mistake. All the time, allthe time most people say that (point) A's cause (point) C's.
That these are the things that make me anxiousor maybe upset or maybe angry. But believe it
or not, A's do not cause C's. We think that way.We talk that way. We explain our world that way.
We say, "gee, you seem kind of freaked out. Youseem kind of agitated today. What's the matter?"
"Well I just found out I've been working withan AIDS patient and a doctor knew it all along
and didn't tell me!" Say well, "gee you know, uh gee,you seem kind of upset. What's the matter, Carol?"
Well gee, "I mean, I just had this exchangewith my husband on the phone and he told
me to burn my clothes.  You know just
because I was working with an AIDS patient. As
though (point) A cause (point) C. A don't cause C.  IfA's don't cause C's, what do cause C's?
B's! Brilliant, but what are (point) B we run into asituation, any of these or any of the day-to-day
examples of these things. What happens at pointB, before you wind up feeling it acting, at point C?
You think, the way you think, will determine how youwind up handling the situation. The way you think
about it. I don't mean the facts. The factswould help you to think rationally about it. But
I can guarantee I've seen lots of people who hadthe facts still don't think rationally. And there's
three screwball ways of thinking. Actually there'sonly four ways of thinking in the whole world.
That's the good news because it's nice
and easy to remember just four of them.
The bad news is that, three out of the
four ways that you could think, stink.
The first type of thinking is called, 'awfulizing'. We awfulize about all kinds of things. It's a
perfect context to look at awfulizing. Everyawfulized thought could be started with the
phrase, "what if, dot, dot, dot." Practitioner:] What if I don't getthe artery on the first try? What if he... Calm down.
What if I get a needle stick? Now concentrate.There, there's the artery. There it is.
[Clinical Instructor:] The second one,
'shooting'. Some of us are absolutely
dynamite at, shooting. We should on ourselves.
We should on other people. How about some of the ways that we should on the homosexual? [Wife/Nurse:] Look
I don't care what they do with the door closed.I just don't see why, we should have to watch!
[Husband:] Joan, you really should try and develop a littlemore of a tolerant attitude. [Wife/Nurse:] Wait a minute.
Let's get something straight here. He shouldn'thave been doing those things in the first place.
We shouldn't have to put up with
the very thing, that caused this disease.
[Clinical Instructor:] Third one, is 180 degrees opposite, 'rationalizations'.
Rationalizations, are where you do the exact
avoidance kind of thing. Some of the things wewere talking about before. "So what, who cares. Big
deal. Doesn't bother me." How do you rationalize, theconflicts in your relationship with your spouse?
Versus your relationship to your profession? You have to rationalize it in order to, say well,
"we just don't talk about it." Practitioner:] I really feel likeI'm caught in a bind. I'm determined to continue
Critical Care Nursing. It's challenging and I'mgood at it I don't know how I'll feel in a year.
We've lost seven AIDS patients on our
unit since I started and that's really
taken a toll on all of us. Course it's
impossible for me to talk to Dan about that
for the time being. I'm not saying anything at homeabout AIDS. It's just not worth the aggravation.
[Clinical Instructor:] That gets you through today, doesn't it? That gets
you through the incident. The rationalizations, the
cons. But they sure don't get you through theongoing process that you have to deal with in
the long run. At some point you got to deal withthe real questions and you have to be real clear
about what it is, that you're going to think. Notjust what facts you know. Not just what procedures
you know. But how am I going to deal with itemotionally? There's a fourth option, fortunately.
It comes out, well, it's what's called, the 'rationaloption' and they come out like this. I want... I like...
I'd prefer...  If.. Would be better if, dot dot dot. I'dlike to have perfect knowledge. I'd like to have
procedures that are absolutely guaranteed, thatif, I follow these procedures there's absolutely
no way, no way possible, that anything could happento me. I'd like all AIDS patients to be charming,
scintillating and thoroughly enjoyable to workwith and totally in agreement with my philosophy
of sexuality. If that was the case, "great!" If it'snot, is it awful, terrible, horrible the end of the
world and I get to make myself excessively anxious,angry, depressed, guilty, frustrated, upset, hassled
harried, irritated and wind up not giving the kindof care that I have committed myself to giving? No.
It's unfortunate. I regret it. I'm concernedabout it and I'm committed to doing a good job.
[Nurse 9:] I think it's great, I mean you know the theoryitself is is fine. But in a highly stressful
situation, like in a healthcare situation, um, itcould be, I could see where it could be difficult
to apply.  I mean even if you've got this downpat and you've thought it out. [Clinical Instructor:] Absolutely. You're
absolutely right, The point that you saidit very tactfully, as opposed to saying, "yeah but Ii
don't think it's going to work in this situation." Ithink the reality is, that it is harder to do it, in
the crisis situation. The stakes are larger, themoment is quicker and sudden. Consequently it's
even more dramatically important, that you learnhow to get control of it, instead of it running you.
And by the way it's not just in a medicalsituation. Anytime you're in any kind of crisis
situation, your first inclination is to overreact. Does overreacting prevent the acquisition of AIDS?
Does it make you feel any better? [Nurse 3:] Itmay help relieve some of the anxiety.
[Clinical Instructor:] Does it make it go away? [Nurse 3:] It doesn't make it goaway. But it helps, um, helps you to feel better
if you have a healthy outlet to ventilate yourfeelings. [Clinical Instructor:] Yes exactly and I really believe that
that some people believe, "that if I can just getit off my chest", and maybe I can put it put it
to rest and and then go on and do my business.My only concern is that isn't what happens
with a lot of people. Is that they do that and thenthey go off and they don't do their business in a
professional manner, because of all the stuff thatthey did agitating themselves. [Nurse 10:] We may work through
this rational thoughts to ourselves and everythingbe just fine. Yet, when you're actually ready to do
a procedure or do something with the patient.To have a physician or a nurse who you respect,
at the last minute say, "I wouldn't do that." It justtakes so little to have that irrational thought
creep back up and build. [Clinical Instructor:] Physicians probably
have just as many wacko overreactions about
AIDS patients as any other population. Thephysicians ought to be talking about, "What the
heck is my feeling," about this person. What are mybiases? What are my fears. You know because in fact
they probably set a standard for everybodyelse. They can throw a curveball in there.
If you really got it together and somebodythrows one of those curveballs in there, like
you're talking about and can set the whole unit,reeling in uncertainty. Okay now I want to go over
the three steps for 'Changing Your Thinking', ifyou find yourself overreacting or that you might
be overreacting to a particular situation. Let'ssay that you find yourself getting agitated, uh
overactive in some situation. You're having todeal with something that you feel strongly about.
So the first question is, what are you thinkingto yourself, about yourself? What are you thinking
to yourself about the others in the situationand what are you thinking about the situation?
The second step in the process is to ask yourselftwo questions. What's true? What is actually
verifiably true? What are the facts?  Then youask yourself the second question, what's not true?
The third step is very simple, you teach
yourself to think in terms of preferences.
Coming down to step three, when you substitutethe the realistic preferences. You're not getting
rid of your feelings. What you're doing is gettingthem down to a level that you can still maintain
your professionalism. You can still work with thepatient in a functional effective manner and you
can still take good emotional care of yourself.As you're going through your responsibilities and
commitments. You are going to have to deal with it, one way shape or form. Some way and what I'm saying
to you is, that the best way that you can possiblydo it, is that step three, that you think in terms
of preferences. I'd certainly like to not getAIDS. I would prefer that this not be a contagious
disease. It would be better if I didn't have anyeven minuscule uncertainty about this. But that's
not the case. Consequently, I am concerned. I regretthat, it's a serious issue and I am committed
to doing a quality job. I want to be real clearwith you about one thing. I am not suggesting
and I'm not suggesting that you believe, thatif you did contract AIDS it wouldn't be awful.
This is one of the few experiences in the world,where in fact, the event really truly is awful.
There are very few things in the world that reallytruly are awful. I mean we think divorces are awful
and we think this thing is awful. And that you knowI lost my car in an accident. This is awful and
that's awful. You know, we we awfulize about thingsthat frankly just pale by comparison. The whole
point about this, what we call rational thinkingis not to eliminate your feelings. You can't. It's
impossible to eliminate feelings. The simple goalis to get those emotional reactions down to a
level that you can't function professionally.That you can take good care of yourself
emotionally.
you